[Applause]
[Music]
we are the tribe
that they cannot see we live
on an industrial reservation
we are the hallucination
we have been called the indians
we have been called native american
we have been called hostile
we have been called pagan
we have been called militant we have
been called
many names we are
the hallucinations we
are the human beings
the callers of names cannot see us
but we can see them
we are the hallucinations
our dna is of earth and sky
our dna is our past and future
we are the nation
we are the evolution
the continuation
[Music]
um
hmm
[Music]
the virus took on many shapes the bear
the elk the antelope the elephant the
deer
the mineral the iron
[Music]
the people
the women and children are separated
from the men they're divided into the
regional filters of their minds
the violence of arrogance crawls into
the air nestles
[Music]
the missionaries never hid their
perspective
prospectors of land would rather see us
disappear
[Music]
recyclable prayers the people
this is my body which is given for you
the people this is my blood
we are not a conquered people
[Music]
[Applause]
the compound was on fire
[Music]
what's up
the compound was on fire
[Music]
the the human beings
the people see the spiritual in the
natural
through sense and feeling everything
is related all the things of earth
and in the sky have spirit everything
is safe confronted by
the alien nation
the subjects and the citizens see the
material religions
through trauma and numb nothing is
related
all the things of the earth and in the
sky
have energy to be exploited
[Music]
even themselves mining their spirits
into souls sold
into nothing is sacred not even
their self
the ally nation alienation
[Music]
is
uh
ancestors live in the dna
in genetic memory the evolution
[Music]
our ancestors with religion
we disappear into religious heavens
and hell
[Music]
human beings we are human
we are
[Music]
foreign
uh
[Music]
human beings
we are of the earth our bone flesh
blood metals minerals liquids
of earth
the reality of our ancestors live
we are the children of earth
[Music]
we are the hallucinations
you